surtout je vous dis la vérité les
téléspectateurs moi je pense c'est ce
que disait raymond à la fois que kylie
ann m pap et gagnent beaucoup d'argent
ça dérange pas que à un immense acteur
gagnent beaucoup d'argent à un immense
humoriste ça dérange moins mais là en
fait tu penses que les gens se disent
qu'elle est leur talent pour gagner
autant d'argent c'est ça en fait qui
dérange qui gagnent des millions est ce
que ça nous dérange pas non c'est pas
tout à fait pareil c'est pas tellement
si elle est jeune elle est belle à
savoir une chose qui dérange moi ça me
dérange pas qu'ils gagnent beaucoup
d'argent non plus qu'on leur foute ces
deux c'est très bien pour eux ce qui
dérange c'est à dubaï pas d'impôts à
redire ici se faire soigner ou à coucher
profiter des aides sociales mais
salvatrice à la
[Applaudissements]
triste mais dans ces cas là on va plus
loin et on prend tous les grands
sportifs qu'on aime qui sont français
qui vivent en suisse en belgique on a
plein de nous on fait un complément d
enquête dessus on les insulte pas que ça
allait pas d'accord non mais tu vois ce
que moi je